bps okay
now all speeds on communications
networks are measured in bps what's it
stand for
uh it stands for bits right as in
bit itself is a abbreviation do you
remember it was an abbreviation for
binary as in zero or one digit
so one bit is a zero or a one uh and the
ps because it's a measurement of
speed it's per second
okay bits per second now therefore
my question is how can you use it to
estimate how long a file will take
to download now here's the tricky bit
okay you remember when we store files on
a computer
right we store them in say for example a
kilobyte
okay kilobyte now what is a kilobyte and
how does a kilobyte
relate to a bit
now kilo means a thousand right but
there are actually not a thousand bytes
in a kilobyte
how many how many bytes are there one
thousand
and twenty four okay and that comes from
the fact that
that's two to the power of ten okay
which is a bit awkward
because it's close to um a thousand but
it's not exactly
you can see the same number coming up
when you think about a megabyte right
it's 2 to the power of 20 okay so i'm
multiplying by
that lot again so you get 1 million
48 576 from memory
if you take 1024 you square it okay
so this is what storing and retrieving
units are okay
but when you download stuff it's just
thinking about bits
okay and bits don't have to come in nice
neat packs of um powers of 10 okay
so for instance the first modem i ever
owned
was rated at 28.8 i don't know always
with 0.8 but anyway
um k b p
s okay blistering speeds all right
now what does this mean um confusingly
the k here for kilo right actually means
a thousand
okay not a thousand twenty four
so the people who made motives and the
people who made hard drives evidently
weren't communicating very well okay um
get it communicating
uh because these units are different all
right
so let's think about this let's take a
file
let's say it's um one megabyte
okay
how long would it have taken my ancient
modem to download it
well i've got things in bytes and i've
got things in bits so what i want to do
is translate everything
into one common unit so which do you
think i should use
should i use bits or bytes
it doesn't actually matter you can use
either one they'll be fine
um i'm gonna go with bytes um the reason
why is because my numbers will not be so
astronomically large but if you've got a
calculator there
either way is fine when you're in an
exam when you're in the hsc
you'll be asked to do a calculation like
this but they're not actually interested
in the number
they're just interested in how you got
there so you won't actually be allowed
to bring a calculator in
but you just have to show this
calculation just like i'm doing for you
now okay
so let's get this all in the same
language this
is we already wrote it 1 million 48
576 bytes
okay one mega byte now what is this
hmm it's 28
800 bits per second
okay so bits bytes how do i turn this
into bytes
bytes are a larger unit so i've got to
divide by eight okay
so i would say twenty eight
eight zero zero b p s
right i'm trying to convert this into
bytes just like i've got these invites
is well let's let's do it shall we okay
thank you
wait exactly yeah 3 600
bites per
second okay so now i've got everything
the same units that's in bytes that's in
bytes
now i just have to divide right divide
this one
by this one and that'll give me the
number of seconds um
now since you guys do have access to
calculators on your computers can you
tell me what the
number of seconds is you divide this
many by this many
someone got it am i going to beat you
there
oh it was too slow okay two nine one
point
one
okay so if we were asked to provide that
in minutes i guess you would say that's
four minutes and 51 seconds yeah happy
okay
so that's how you go from one to the
other the careful the thing you have to
be careful for
is um what units you're in now here's
what i want you to do
i want you to find a website on the
internet and i've given you an example
of one
but i actually would like you to
purposely find different ones okay
find some in australia find some
different countries and so on and so on
i want you to test the school's upload
and download speeds
okay so when you go here it'll show you
you'll come up with something and it'll
say start a test and you can start it in
a variety of different ways
okay and i want you to make a record
like either on paper
or in a spreadsheet or something like
that um of
the speed actually you know what i'm
going to set up a google spreadsheet i
don't have to get you guys to alter it
separately let's try and aggregate this
data
okay so here you go you can see you can
begin the test don't fall for that
that's just an ad because it'll get you
to do something else
okay begin the test and then off it goes
okay
there you go did you see that so there's
the actual time in um that's the
response time
okay and off it goes and anyway i want
you to all do that do it on different
spots i'm going to set up a google
spreadsheet
i want you to have um set up
who your name what your name is okay and
if it gives you the ping
write down the ping uh and download
speed and upload speed oh it's slowing
down
it's getting there eventually okay so
okay now it'll tell us the full results
in a minute i suspect it's in
um millions of bits per second so it's
still bps
okay there you go see bps mbps